in this video we will discuss the Coombs
test and before discussing the Coombs
test it is very important to understand
the concept of the autoantibody so this
is an RPC and on the surface of the RPC
there are lots of antigens for example
the [ __ ] blood grouping antigens the RH
antigens and many others and some
conditions of the body for example the
immuno hemolytic anemias the body
produces certain types of antibodies
which are directed against these
antigens and these antibodies attach to
these antigens and cause immune mediated
destruction of the RBC's and lead to
anemia and this antibody is known as the
or xx body and the Coombs test is a test
which is done to detect these types of
antibodies so there are two types of
Coombs test the direct type and the
indirect type and the common thing in
both of them is the Coombs reagent and
it is very important to understand the
Coombs reagent how it is made what is it
to understand the basics of the Coombs
test so let's first understand how is
the Coombs reagent made please excuse me
for my drawings but let's suppose this
is a human and the body of this human
contains lots of these Auto antibodies
so what we do is we take the blood from
this human and we separate the serum
from this blood which contains all of
these or 20 bodies and what we do next
is that we inject this serum into an
animal please don't ask me whatever
animal is this it just is now the immune
system of this animal recognizes these
antibodies as foreign and produces its
own antibodies against these and what we
do next is we take the blood of that
animal and separate those antibodies
which the animal has just produced
against these or 20 bodies and we
harvest those antibodies and this is the
Coombs reagent so the Coombs reagent is
nothing but the antibodies which the
body of the animal has produced against
the
Auto antibodies let's first talk about
the direct Coombs test and out of the
two types of the kun test this is the
one which is used to detect the immuno
hemolytic anemias so let's suppose this
is a human which has immuno hemolytic
anemia and his blood contains Auto
antibodies which are directed against
his RBC's so what we do is we take the
blood sample from this patient and we
put that blood into a test tube or a
beaker so here are the RBC's which are
present in the blood of this patient and
here are those antibodies which are
attached to the RBC surface and to keep
things simple for the rest of the video
I will refer to these Auto antibodies as
blue antibodies and the antibodies which
are present in the Coombs reagent as
green an tea parties what we do next is
we add the Coombs reagent which has
these anti Auto antibodies or the green
antibodies into this blood sample now
since these green antibodies are
directed against these blue antibodies
when they react they call the attachment
of these blue antibodies and since in
turn these blue antibodies are bound to
the RBC's it forms a gluten ated mass of
the RBC's at the bottom of the test tube
or the beaker so here is the
agglutinated mass of the RBC's and this
is a visible reaction which confirms the
presence of Auto antibodies in the blood
sample and one of the very important
condition in which the direct Coombs
test is done is the hemolytic disease of
the newborn which is also a type of
immune or humidity anemia now let's talk
about the indirect type of the Coombs
test and this test is mainly done for
the prenatal screening of females for
detection of RH antibodies sorry this is
a writing mistake this is antibody not
antigen let's suppose this is a pregnant
female and again it excuse me for my
fantastic drawings and let's suppose
this is a fetus inside her womb the
female is Rh negative and the fetus is
Rh positive so what happens is sometimes
at the time of the pasteurization the
fetal blood comes in contact with a
maternal blood and
maternal blood develops anti-rh
antibodies against those RBC's and
during the second pregnancy if the fetus
is again an Rh positive human the
antibodies these cross the placenta and
destroy those fetal RBC's so it is very
important to detect those antibodies so
what we do is we take the blood from the
female and after some procedures like
washing and centrifugation we separate
the serum from the blood and we add the
serum into a test you same as that of
before and here lies those antibodies
the anti RH antibodies now here is the
essential step which is different from
that of the diary type of the Coombs
test
now since the maternal blood does not
contain those RBC's to which these anti
RH antibodies will bind so we will have
to introduce externally the Rh positive
blood so the next step will be addition
of Rh positive RBC's either of the
animal type or the human type into this
sample so again these antibodies will
bind to these Rh positive or B C's and
the next step in this are the same as
that of the data type of the Coombs test
so when we add the Coombs reagent into
this sample these antibodies again bind
to these anti RH antibodies and cause
the agglutination so agglutinated mass
of our PCs is formed at the bottom of
the test tube so this was all about the
Coombs test I hope you find this video
informative make sure to hit the like
button below and also if you want more
videos don't forget to subscribe thank
you so much for watching this video